come on Sandro drop pretty good collar
girl you're neutral hell pretty that is
your girl get a little oil guy
counterclockwise it comes out of it
every now and then we like up stand it
background take a shot
there i got a good brown you go from
rights under Title nice number two man
we got him boom baby pop but what is
very common
now that people will
good and bad
now that's a nice one at is a jumbo
that's awesome as a nice spot already
made remember right let's see we got 98
inches number two for the commercial
sees what that's a nice picture at that
he'll number to that park next to no one
hey Paul command command we just click
the second one and all its Dave you know
he's just super competitive
yeah we got all nite nite fish when i
started meeting around other boats
dot-com catching fish and he ended up
picking up Oliver all your child right
into how to catch the roof and paid off
a little bit of locking don't think that
it's just it's all good you know